[Applause]
hey sir
give me a favor
come this way
[Applause]
give me one second
[Applause]
he said well
at this point all right uh can you uh
the officers explain what's going on
when we're on them not really man all
right so we gotta call this i heard if
the irish might ask me if i'll pass them
no yeah
so basically we got a call and uh from
what we got the call it seems like
someone was trying to rob the bank uh
something about you passing a note to
the teller something to that effect uh
can you just tell me what's going on
you know because it's a large amount she
works a lot yeah
you know if i if i don't if i don't
write down a note
how much i went out
and then i don't want to run through the
money right there at the desk
the whole bank ends up looking at me
because they just drink what are you
going to do
and i don't feel safe i'll feel safe
getting money out like that so every
time i go to withdraw it
you know i put that i put the amount the
account when they're taking all that up
and then i put my own card in and then i
and then i usually take me out like oh
it's just just get to get the money you
know what i'm saying the teller
she started to freak out so she didn't
even match the accounts with his id that
she gave him
so i need to double check to see if
that's even the account his account
that's what i'm saying because if that
is he doing that
officers that arrest me
that had that had that glocks out yeah
so i was pulling money on my own account
i understand i put the i put my own bank
card in there
before the light you went in the back
you know what i'm saying so
we have to confirm that you gotta
understand we can't we don't come out
because of the seriousness of the co-op
you don't just come out and
unfortunately in a situation like that
you don't get the benefit of the doubt
we detain and then we ask questions
later
that's what exactly what i went inside
for uh basically we got a call
from i believe the teller saying that uh
someone slipped a note
basically made it appear as if the bank
was being robbed by somebody they give a
description and things like that
that's why we came out and we detained
everybody like explained to him
unfortunately in those situations we
take an abundance of caution because we
don't know what's going on
that's why you were detained once we
figured out
that they called and
she's saying that i guess she wasn't
speaking and that's an impressive note
and that's why she was she was nervous
and stalling she wanted to let i have no
idea i didn't talk to her